des accusations américaines qui risquent
encore de ternir les relations entre la
Chine et les États-Unis
selon le secrétaire d'État américain
Anthony blinken Washington disposerait
d'informations selon lesquelles Pékin
pourrait fournir une aide de guerre
létale à la Russie
c'est ce qu'a révélé le chef de la
diplomatie à la télévision dimanche
questionner sur sa rencontre avec son
homologue chinois Munich
oui
à ce jour nous avons vu des entreprises
chinoises fournir un soutien non létal à
la Russie pour une utilisation en
Ukraine ce qui nous préoccupe maintenant
c'est que d'après les informations dont
nous disposons ils envisagent de fournir
un soutien létal et nous leur avons fait
savoir très clairement que cela poserait
un sérieux problème pour nous et dans
nos relations
des relations déjà tumultueuses alors
que le soutien militaire de la Chine à
la Russie est une question régulièrement
soulevée par Washington et
systématiquement nié par Pékin le
ministère chinois des Affaires
étrangères a publié dans la foulée en
communiquée indiquant que le pays
n'acceptait pas que les États-Unis
pointent du doigt ou même exerce une
pression coercitive sur les relations
chines Russie
la Maison Blanche est aussi préoccupée
par les importants échanges commerciaux
entre Moscou et Pékin avec les sanctions
européennes la Russie s'est tournée vers
la Chine qui devient un marché
indispensable pour exporter pétrole gaz
et charbon
Anthony blinken n'a pas hésité à mettre
en garde la Chine sur les conséquences
d'un soutien économique à la Russie
alors que la Chine c'est toujours gardée
de condamner l'invasion russe en Ukraine